I mean it's just a complicated messy fun
very dramatic messy role and it's just
I'm always gravitating towards those
sorts of roles but that's just the type
of things that I love to sink my teeth
into you know
[Music]
Westworld season 3 here we are here we
are at now your we are before your cast
yeah
were you a fan or did you do the binge
no I was a crazy fan I I think I had
already seen the second season twice
before I sat down with Lisa and Jonah so
I was trying to keep my cool during my
meeting but they had a great pitch for
me and they were really excited about
the idea of me joining the show so yeah
I was great we get to experience this
new world this outside world really
through Caleb's eyes yeah break it down
for the fans out there what can you
tease about your character yeah well I
mean you know any fan of Westworld knows
that the first two seasons really mainly
took place within the walls the confines
of of West world and so caleb is a
character that sort of introduces the
audience to the society beyond the walls
of West's world and it's great you know
he's a complicated guy he has a
complicated past and those more and more
of those layers are revealed throughout
this season of who this guy really is
not everything really is as it seems and
true West world fashion even if we're
outside of the walls of West's world
it's still very complicated and messy
and very similar to the inner workings
of West World War II Dolores
you and I are a lot alike they put you
in the cage decided what your life would
be I did the same thing to me what was
it like for you and Evan to share that
first scene together and to really get
to act off of each other you know I'm
such a huge fan of Evan as as a human as
an artist and as Dolores and so to be
able to go to work and zip on this this
character's skin and and play opposite
her and it's really truly such a dream
come true you know I was so blessed with
Breaking Bad I thought that was really
capturing lightning in a bottle and I
really feel like I'm jumping into yet
another magical show such as that one
and it's really such a blessing well
speaking of Breaking Bad I feel like
West's role is very similar in it and
that everything is deliberate mm-hmm
have very eagle-eyed fans looking for
those little hints that will pay off
later yeah of course the West world fans
noticed throughout the trailer that at
one point Dolores says to your character
Kaleb they put you in a cage and all the
Breaking Bad fans immediately thought of
Jesse pinkman's no season on Breaking
Bad what did you think of the
correlation are we entering super meta
world haha you know I never even really
thought about that but yeah it's just
it's so crazy what a science fiction
show Westworld is but it feels like it's
really kind of based on some sort of
distant reality what's just terrifying
we've been watching me
not me but someone something
what has been the most rewarding part
for you to play Caleb oh my god the list
is endless really but first and foremost
the fact that we shoot in Los Angeles I
haven't I haven't shot in LA in a very
long time actually I shot this Apple
show in LA I was the first time I worked
in LA in over 10 years but to be able to
be in a world that Lisa and Jonah
created and science fiction being my
favorite genre and being on a show that
is one of my favorite shows of all time
is is really um it's kind of an aha
I'm almost like my god it's uh it's all
happening you know it's a it's a
beautiful thing and I feel so blessed so
yeah just have a job you know I think is
the biggest blessing well not to put
that job in jeopardy but I do know that
you are a fan of swiping things from set
whenever I do a job what job that I love
I tend to steal things from sets because
if you ask they always say no this is
from El Camino surprise I stole this
what well now did you not true what did
you taken anything from West world West
world coasters in your Idaho home that
was a gift
thank you Lisa thank you Jonah did you
do you have anything that's Caleb's um
honestly to be honest no have I tried
absolutely but I always go to the prop
Department would this be okay no this is
H and they're like no no no maybe you
should talk to Joan about that at night
I would tease Jonah like you know I'm
gonna steal this thing and he would give
me this death stare and I quickly
realized maybe I shouldn't steal from
Jonah
Nolan jumping way ahead when you read
this season 3 finale oh my god uh I was
begging for the finale we all were for
so long
you know sometimes we get the scripts a
little ahead in advance but sometimes
it's just like a night before we start
shooting it this was definitely one of
those times
it was exciting you know I I had it on
my lap I just I poured a nice big glass
of red wine and I just slowly took my
time with it and it's a wild one
[Music]